u
liebe lena auch nach zwei wochen muss
ich noch ständig daran denken dass mit
philipp einfach so unheimlich
aber es hilft das reeser immer da ist
und auch lotte wir haben uns wieder
vertragen sie hat es schwer wieder zu
vertrauen
aber da ist sie nicht allein mark hatte
ich auch unrecht getan ich habe mich
entschuldigt aber ob wir freunde bleiben
können
das weiß ich nicht ich muss jetzt
schluss machen
heute ist der große abend
damals wirklich nicht mit anpacken habe
ich dann nicht schon genug getan
das hast du
das hast du wirklich
so kann ich noch immer
war ich neidisch über tod gesagt habe
war nicht richtig in ordnung
ok
so hat seine freundin lebendig besorgt
meine freundin
unaufgeregt
auf dem kuhberg foto
ohne deinen vorschlag vielleicht den job
los geworden das war echt eine super
idee
danke dass du zurückgekommen ist
danke dass du mir endlich mal zugehört
hat
freunde
oder geschäftspartnerin
du meinst du das
foto
ich habe mich wie ein arsch
mit dabei die wichtigste regel meiner
kleinen formuliert
kreative mitarbeiter belohnen
willst du bei mir anfangen
als partnerin
du machst das design und hass ideen
und ich mach dir krise